make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so I've been sitting here thinking
about villains in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe right like like what comes
after Santos right like like people kind
of talk about that like there was there
was a really cool video released by
everything always where it was like how
Avengers in game sets of Galactus and
things like that because I watch a lot
of comic book and geek centric youtubers
a lot of you guys don't really seem to
believe that but there's a lot of comic
book youtubers that I watch like I'm
probably if you're coming with youtuber
out there I'm probably like like you
know sneaking around and watching your
channel very sneakily but but
nonetheless I was sitting here thinking
about that and I was like you know I
want to start a series of videos where
we talk about like villains in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe right like why
I think they would be a good fit not
even not even anything like too powerful
for the Marvel movies right under which
which we out of that's coming bad you
know what that's gonna come Saturday we
probably do one about a version of
spider-man
um I know exactly what version
spider-man I'm going to do but Saturday
we'll bring that back ah cuz we kind of
took a break from it because like
Avengers in game can you really blame me
but um anyway um I was I was like you
know it's not really gonna be exactly
like that look right like here's how
this villain would overpower the MCU um
I was thinking about it from the
perspective of like why they would be an
awesome character like why they would be
an awesome villain because Feige and
them had had come out previously before
Avengers in game and said okay we kind
of realized the error of killing off our
buildings right because like how you
know cuz we're running out of them you
know we killed off Red Skull
quote-unquote I mean of course what
school still exists just not in the same
form it's just kind of a spirit that
hangs out around that planet was it the
planet were a Faramir or for me or
whatever it is where the the soulstone
was but um but like you know the red
schools there you know this kind of in a
spiritual form well they could bring him
back and that's that was something else
kind of hesitant about right like kneel
people were like red skulls and Infinity
Ward I'm just like what you know like
like what's the red school doing
Infinity Ward and when I saw him like
when when I thought that I was like okay
how do you do it without the the matrix
guy care what his name is the guy that
played agent Smith um how do you do it
without him
and then like I saw that version of of
Red Skull and I was like Hugo Weaving
that's what it is and I saw that version
of red school and I was like okay that
works and so so I mean some of the
villains could kind of make a return but
like Obadiah Stane you know Iron Monger
he's dead
he's gone he's out of the picture you
know a lot it a lot of villains like
that or are no longer you know never to
be seen and so with fighting them saying
hey like we don't really want to keep
killing off our villains or at least you
know we kind of paraphrasing putting
words in their mouth you know we don't
really want to keep killing villains we
want to kind of bring them in and then I
guess keep them around you know so that
we can do something with him later on
down the line it presents the
opportunity to bring in a lot of awesome
villains because the thing about Thanos
is that as interesting as he is and as
upset as I was about the fact that they
killed him off there are villains out
there who are actually a lot more
intriguing and in this video I want to
talk about Doctor Doom we did a video
previously where it was like you know
like too powerful of Marvel movies
god-king doom I want to kind of leave
out the secret worst version of Doctor
Doom I mean we'll mention him here but I
want to talk about why Doctor Doom would
be an amazing villain the reason for
this is what I when I look at villains
and I determine the difference between
an amazing villain and a great villain
an amazing villain is one that's like
that that's almost relatable that you
look at that in the way they're written
the way they're done either in one story
arc for multiple story arcs is done in
such a way towards like either I can
identify with my character
or I think they're their character
progression is kind of cool because for
years and years and years Doctor Doom
was a bad guy and then Secret Wars 2015
happen and when Bendis was riding him he
basically had this attitude of like dr.
doom has a new lease on life and so when
iron man died after Civil War - dr. doom
became in the Lion Man right like he
took up the mantle he became the new
Iron Man for a while and it was awesome
like it was it was it was I mean some
people kind of complained about it but I
think like 99% of the people who saw the
story of Doctor Doom being Iron Man
thought it was awesome where the very
least was an awesome concept and I loved
it I loved the the costume I loved his
whole motivation he went through it just
like was like eradicating villains and
things like that
not really Punisher life but you know
like like dealing with villains that had
long since been like a menace to the
superhero community things like that and
so I look at that and I say okay like
dr. doom would be awesome in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
and the reason for this is because
people look at at doom and they say okay
he's a villain of the fantastic force
you so you could put him in the MCU but
he would be restricted to the Fantastic
Four and that's true but not true at the
same time and the reason why a lot of
non comic book readers say that is
because in movie form he's only ever
been a villain of the Fantastic Four and
even when they know about and they know
him as a fantastic floor foe that's
because by and large they're probably
not aware of stories like secret wars
1984 they're probably not aware of
stories like to do more like Seagal Wars
2015 different things like that
Doctor Doom when it comes to being a
villain and I can't really blame I mean
they never really read comics but like
dr. doom as a villain is it's pretty
much a villain everyone because dr. doom
has fought everyone but like dr. doom
has fought the x-men there was one point
where Doctor Doom fought the x-men the
Fantastic Four and ambi Avengers all at
the same time and actually one for a
little while and that was actually the
story do more I'll talk about that here
in a second um but Doctor Doom is he's a
complicated character right like like
you you you you look at him and it's
very easy to track him up to being like
your stereotypical villain right like
I'm a bad guy and I do bad things
because that's what that guys do not at
all the Doctor Doom for example like
like there's there's this one moment and
what is it in and Jonathan Hickman
Avengers and New Avengers when name was
a submariner forms a cabal with like
Thanos and basically the black order the
same black order that you saw from from
infinity war and the idea is they want
to stop the incursion if you don't know
what that means it doesn't really matter
for the sake of this of this part of the
discussion but there's one point where
the Cabal basically gets out of control
and name where doesn't really know how
to reel them back in right like their
job was to go through and just destroy
worlds but Thanos and the black order
actually relish and like torturing
people
well there's one point where like they
kill all the x-men on in one universe
and then they like forced Charles Xavier
to like beg them to kill him right I
mean it's this craziness twisted but
Namor goes to Doctor Doom and he's just
like I don't know how to corral this in
any more and doctor dooms response is
like you know you I understand your
dalliance is with you know your your
your your goings on with like Reed
Richards and like Tori Stark and those
guys in the Illuminati because you
thought you were doing the life thing
but then like instead of coming to me
after you left you through your lot in
with Thanos and the black border and
then here you come dragging the stinking
carcass of your failure to my front door
no that's not gonna happen
now and it's one of the crazy things
because like like he's just like no I'm
not gonna help you like I'm not going to
help you out and I guess maybe you kind
of require a context to really
understand the significance of that
situation but it's a it's a great moment
because when it comes to Doctor Doom as
a character uh he's very very prideful
right like Doctor Doom is exceedingly
arrogant and full of hubris but
rightfully so but at the same time he's
also caring right like during that same
exchange with name whether Submariner um
is it like like name word he calls into
question doctor dooms role is like the
leader of Liberia right like the the
king or the emperor of Liberia the
country that Doctor Doom reigns over and
Doctor Doom kind of responds and he says
do you really believe that if the people
in this country wanted to kill me that
they couldn't rise up and destroy me
like you really believe that couldn't
happen if you do you're a fool he's like
he's like but I keep them protected I
give I make sure they're safe I make
sure that when they go to sleep at night
they don't have anything to worry about
I get them food you know he's always
like when they go to bed before they
pray to whatever God they pray to you
they give thanks to me and it's just
like damn it's like one of the most
arrogant things ever but it's true dr.
doom is fiercely protective of his
people if somebody weren't like like if
for whatever reason Wolverine for devil
lost his mind and like decided he was
gonna go attack Liberia and just started
indiscriminately killing Liberian
citizens Oh dr. doom would tear him limb
from limb he would rip him apart dr.
doom does not abide those who try to do
wrong by his people he protects them he
keeps them safe he's the guy that rules
that place and he does it not really
with a harsh hand but like she was a
very caring and with a kind hand you
know you're with a with a benign hand
you actually see that Andrew Baker's
books of doom right at the origin of
Doctor Doom when he takes over Liberia
because before dr. doom there was this
Emperor who was just a dick who treated
everybody terribly and so dooms like if
I'm going to be a ruler in a king I'm
not gonna be like that guy but then you
look at dr. doom on the other side where
he's like coveting absolute power right
because and Jonathan Hickman's run of
the Fantastic Four
and there was this really really good
story where dr. doom I'm sorry where
Reed Richards another really good story
there's a really good point where Reed
Richards of course encounters a Council
of reeds basically like all this huge
gathering of these alternate reality
versions of himself and they they take
him through and they show him different
worlds where they're doing different
things and fixing various problems and
so on and so forth and then suddenly
they get this great big huge alert and
it's like dr. doom and some universe
somewhere is doing something to try to
gain absolute power or whatever and when
the Council of reeds brings Reed
Richards from the main Marvel Universe
with them to fight that version of
Doctor Doom once they defeat him they
lobotomize him and they stick him below
the Citadel like the the base of
operations for the Council of reeds and
when Reed asks why you do that you know
he's like why do you guys do this and
why are there so many other verses of
Doctor Doom who have been lobotomized
and are sitting under here the council
says because dooms quest for power is
absolute doom will never give up on
trying to acquire absolute power he'll
never stop his his lust for power is as
unquenchable it can never be satisfied
he will always try to gain absolute
power if there's more power to be
coveted he will try to attain it and it
was it was a really cool moment because
that's true about Doctor Doom he's kind
of selfish and he's easy he's very he's
very prideful he's very caring towards
his people for everybody else he's very
cold and if there's a way for him to
expand his power he always will and
we've seen that in a multitude of
different ways right like he threw in
with a group called the intelligentsia
and the intelligentsia was an
organization and actually I think he was
a part of it for a while and so they
took him and then like screwed with his
brain but the intelligentsia was an
organization of various supervillains
who were largely exceedingly smart and
they were kind of plotting and planning
their own ends in order to hunt and try
to conquer the world or something like
that but doom threw him with them for a
little while um in this in the story not
in and was it secret Wars in 1984 the
original secret Wars book Doctor Doom
steals the power of Galactus and then he
steals the power of the Beyonder who is
more powerful than anybody who existed
in the throughout the entirety of Marvel
Comics with the exception of the one
above all I think and like Doctor Doom
stole his power because he's like I'm
trying to attain absolute power and the
story do more Doctor Doom actually goes
in to Latveria and then basically like
like gathers with a whole bunch of of
radical fundamentalist Nationals these
guys who basically look at the chala
and and uh
shuri his sister who I think we she
wasn't the new black panther at the time
actually splaying that here in a second
and then storm who's of course at the
time was the life of black panther and
those are those guys basically trying to
move Wakanda into becoming more in tune
with like the rest of the world right
like opening their doors and they say we
want to be a part of the rest of the
world instead of being isolationist like
what you saw at the end of was a
catheter I don't think was Captain
America's Civil War um well I'm sorry
the end of Black Panther where he said
like we want we don't really want to
like invite everybody into Wakanda but
recently want to play more of a role in
the world instead of being so closed off
though these these radical
fundamentalist didn't like that and so
Doctor Doom went in there and was like
hey I will help you guys
Allyson's T'Challa and his sister Sheree
and storm I will help you guys do that
he funded a coup d'etat in Wakanda and
it was successful it worked like like
literally those guys went in guns and
everything and they overthrew via the
reign of black panther and in fact but
during that whole skirmish and maybe was
right before that happen but during that
skirmish um black panther I guess
T'Challa is injured and he has to like
cede the throne to his sister Shuri and
so sure he becomes a new black panther
and that's why it is you know following
that and really going into like Secret
Wars 2015 and then after Secret Wars
2015 black panther is not in charge of
Wakanda anymore it's his sister she's
the one that runs it because it all came
out of doom or um but but like they're
basically ousted right like storm is
she's in prison and like to Charla and
sure you're on the run they run to like
the x-men and they're like hey like you
guys are friends with storm we've had a
lot of dealings over the years we've
teamed up we've done a lot of things
together like I need you guys to help me
defeat Doctor Doom in Wakanda and so
like they end up recruiting the Avengers
who in turn recruit the Fantastic Four
and so like you have this huge gathering
of forces to face off against Doctor
Doom and the reason why is because dr.
dude's whole motivation for doing this
was taking all the vibranium in Wakanda
and the reason why was because vibranium
amplifies magical energy and so Doctor
Doom is like if I have all that
vibranium I can amp up my powers and
then become godlike and he did like he
was he was godly in terms of his power
like it was almost completely a news he
was like in depth at that forum that he
was in with that kind of power he was
unstoppable
nobody could defeat him the only way
they they were able to beat him is why
Panther had to render all vibranium
across the world and
it was just a useless chunk of rock the
principles in the the the aspects of
vibranium that made it so valuable were
gone right like it was it was it was
like he liked it was believed he
destroyed his country's economy at the
same time and while that's not true
because they might have a bunch of
national debt
what Conda was nowhere near as rich as
it had been before um but literally like
like that kind of a story is a kind of
story you could see in the MCU but but
think about the character of Iron Man of
Tony Stark right like when I Man one
came out Tony Stark was basically
two-dimensional he was a weapons
manufacturer who had a change of heart
because he was taken prisoner and
realized what his weapons have done to
young people and then he decided to
become Iron Man like okay cool like
that's superhero storytelling 101 it's
the most formulaic story you could
possibly tell it's age old and it's
timeless but then you look at Tony you
look at Tony Stark and Iron Man 2 and
Iron Man 3 and like Captain America
Civil War and like Avengers 1 2 and 3
and I guess one to you and then infinity
war and of interesting game you look at
like the entire evolution in Spider Man
homecoming you look at the evolution of
Tony Stark from the first Iron Man movie
all the way to the end of Avengers
endgame and like literally that whole 10
years is the arc of Tony Stark it's it's
that's that's what I would call it the
age of Iron Man is what I would call
that phase because it was all about like
the progression of Tony Stark and as a
viewer you grew with him but you you you
look at that and you became attached to
him because you understood the struggle
of Tony Stark you understood his
mistakes you realized he was screwing up
but at the end of the day he was trying
to do the right thing and so at the end
of Avengers in game when Tony Stark
sacrifices his life there was a reason
why people were crying in the movie
theater because it was just like am i a
man's dead but if he had died in the
first movie it wouldn't matter to you as
much because you would have hardly
understood him at all because he had
been around for two and a half hours as
far as you were aware and so so when you
look at that and then you take a
character like Doctor Doom who in the
comics is actually a lot more nuanced a
lot more interesting and a lot more
complex and Tony Stark is and you throw
me the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
then you leave him there for you know 15
years or something like that and you
give him five movies to expand the
character it becomes awesome because
there's so much you can do with him
there's so much you can do with this
character and there's so much growth
because then you see that like he's a
tortured character like it's he's a
rough character like he lost his mom his
mom sold her soul to Mephisto who's
basically the devil
and like dr. diehl has basically been
trying to get his mom's soul back ever
since because if you read the comics
that's why he tries to acquire absolute
power that's the basis behind it that's
the motivation behind it
Doom wants absolute power so he can
rescue his mom's soul from the devil
that's basically it so he can free his
mom and let her live a happy afterlife
that's it but like you you look at the
comics and all the steps he takes and
the terrible things he does and you
realize it's all for what's genuinely a
good cause for someone other than
himself and it changes your entire
perspective of why Doctor Doom does what
he does so again like I think he'd make
an amazing villain in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe I think he'd be
fantastic and I think he would be he he
would he'd probably be one of the best
villains you've ever seen in film form
if he's written right across all the
movies he appears on but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here - comments
explained make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the Rob before
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and let me know what you
think down in the comment section about
this video and I well I guess that's
this video type and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
you